Okay.
Good afternoon and welcome to talks at Google in Cambridge,
Massachusetts.
Today it's my great pleasure to introduce Beth Shapiro.
Dr Shapiro is here today to discuss her book,
how to clone a mammoth,
the science of de Extinction.
We have the science today to restore extinct species to life,
but should we be ethical?
Challenges are enormous.
Using DNA collected from remains as a genetic blueprint.
Scientists aim to engineer extinct traits,
traits that evolve by natural selection over thousands of years into living
organisms,
but rather than viewing de extinction as a way to restore one particular
species,
she argues with the overarching goal should be to the revitalization and
stabilization of Contemporary Echo Systems.
Doctor Sapiro is an evolutionary biologist who integrates molecular
phylogenetics with advanced computational bio statistics to reconstruct the
influences on population dynamics in a wide variety of organisms.
She is associate professor of ecology and evolutionary biology at UC Santa Cruz.
Her work has appeared in numerous publications including nature and science and
she was a 2009 MacArthur foundation fellow.
Please join me in welcoming Beth Shapiro.
Thank you.
Well,
thank you very much for inviting me to come here and for taking the time out of
your busy and hectic days to come and listen to me,
especially after David did coffee,
who I'm sure it was quite entertaining and maybe probably more entertaining than
I can possibly be.
So let's just leave it at that,
right?
I thought we'd begin with a video that kind of explains what I do when I'm in
the field.
So the quality of the sound is a little bit poor,
but the video is kind of neat.
So bear with me here for just a sec.
Just found,
you can see one,
two,
three,
four pieces here.
This is hard.
So you can see how big.
The neat thing about this is that these are the small pieces,
which means that this stuff is washed downstream.
These pieces are actually still frozen in the permafrost.
You can't get them down the goal.
You're going to be really well preserved.
Just heard that big splash of water back there.
Here comes the water.
We better get outta here.
So
that last part is a little bit ridiculous,
but in my defense,
the water is really gross.
Like what that is,
that's um,
active plaster mining gold binding sites up near Dawson City in Canada's Yukon
territory.
So during the spring when the snow melts,
the miners collect all the water in these big holding ponds and then they pump
it up to whatever they're trying to wash away that permafrost and they wash away
whatever thought and then let it stop for a bit,
let the next little few inches thought,
and then wash that away.
Their goal is to get rid of the,
all of that permafrost to get to the gold bearing gravels beneath.
But while they're doing that,
we find hundreds,
thousands,
sometimes tens of thousands of these bones that are incredibly well preserved
and we bring them back to the lab and use them for research.
So I'm a biologist.
I'm an evolutionary biologist or a geneticist or molecular paleontologist.
Lots of ways to describe that,
including some new ones that were used in the introduction just a moment ago.
Um,
so what,
what does a biologist wants to do with frozen bones?
Collected from the permafrost?
Well,
my research is actually focused on trying to understand how populations and
communities and ecosystems respond to rapid,
large scale changes in climate in the present day.
So when we see and hear about climate change going on today,
often what we hear about are large scale changes in precipitation patterns that
change the distribution of water,
maybe differences in storms and of course species that are on the verge of
extinction.
And when we hear about this stuff reported by the popular press,
often we're just told that everything is going to hell in a handbasket right?
But if you're a biologist and you want to avoid some of these particularly dire,
dire predictions here,
you might want to understand or be able to predict in some useful way.
How will the species and communities that we're trying to protect are going to
respond for the change and the climate that's predicted for the next decade to
century.
So if you keep up with the climate change literature at all,
you'll no doubt be familiar with this particular graph here or something similar
to this.
This is,
um,
Michael Mann's hockey stick graph.
It's called a hockey stick graph because it kind of looks like a hockey stick
laying on its side.
Here's the end of the stick and the part that goes up here.
This is the average temperature around 1960 and this is really just a plot of
how that temperature has changed over the last thousand years.
So you see the temperature remained pretty constant,
maybe declining a little bit through time until a couple of hundred years ago
when it shot up pretty quickly.
Now this plot can be extended into the future and we see all sorts of
predictions of climate increasing the temperature increasing exponentially
throughout the next 50 years to 100 years.
Of course,
this is not the first time in Earth's recent history that the planet has
experienced a really rapid increase in temperature.
If we extend this plot backward to the last 50,000 years,
we see an interval right here in between around 18,000 years ago and maybe 12 or
13,000 years ago when the average global temperature increased by about eight
degrees.
This here is only about one and a half degrees.
This is an eight degree increase.
Some of the work that we're doing right now is suggesting that this last period
of really rapid increase,
this is the transition from the peak of the last ice age into the Holocene warm
interval that we're experiencing today.
This last period possibly happened over less than a hundred years or even as
quickly as a few decades.
So this is a very rapid period of widespread global warming that's going to be
associated with all sorts of changes in temperature and precipitation and
changes to the biological species that are living out there.
So what I tried to do with my research is asked the question,
how did species and communities and populations and ecosystems change,
uh,
in response to this past period of rapid climate change?
And is there anything that we can use from learning about what happened in the
past to make better decisions about how to spend the limited time and energy and
resources?
We have to conserve species today.
So the field I work in is called ancient DNA.
It's pretty clear what ancient DNA means.
Means old DNA,
not old people DNA,
but actually really old DNA like mammoths preserved in ice.
I work at a place called Beringia.
Berenjena spans this kind of part of Alaska here across the Bering land bridge
into eastern Siberia.
All of this white stuff here is just an indication that the,
the,
it's not as deep in the ocean there.
So when the,
during the ice ages,
when much of the water on the planet was taken up into making giant glaciers
sitting on top of the continents,
this was actually exposed.
This was exposed land.
And this of course is a very important corridor for movement of many species,
camels and horses going in this direction.
Bison and people going in this direction to move between the two continents.
So today Bringi looks like this.
I'm actually in that helicopter taking this picture and I'll show you a picture
of that fantastic flying machine in just a moment.
And it looks like this,
but in the past and during the last ice age,
it looked more like this with a very rich and diverse plant community that was
grazed on by rich and diverse herbivore community that was haunted by lots of
different types of carnivores.
There were mammoths and mastodons at various times and North American camels,
several different species of big cat that were giant bears.
Arcadis that if it's stood up was 16 feet tall and there was even a giant
Campbell,
uh,
sorry,
a giant beaver that was the same size as me,
which is I'm the funniest extinct animal.
So we fly out here in this fantastic flying machine.
You'll notice that there are some windows missing,
which is great in case anybody wants to smoke on board and celebration of taking
off.
I'm not saying that happened,
but I'm not saying it didn't.
Then we stay in five star combination.
As you can see here,
this is a picture that I took of my tent by backing up and unfocusing my camera
lens that I could really get a picture of the depth of field of mosquitoes that
we were dealing with up there in the Arctic and we walk along all sorts of
places,
wherever the permafrost is thawing like these plaster mining sites.
This is again back in Dawson city.
The previous pictures were from the time your peninsula and north central
Siberia.
This is a,
again,
an active mining site where you see them washing down the permafrost in here,
my folks kind of wandering around waiting to pick up bones that are coming out
as the dirt washes away,
so in a day out in the field will generally collect anywhere between five and 20
bags of bones like this.
Most of the bones there are bison.
There are also mammoth and Caribou and horses and sometimes we get lucky and get
wolves or bears or lions,
and we take a piece out of these bones,
a tiny piece that's just a regular dremmel tool with little cutting desk and
bring that piece back to the lab,
grinded up and extract DNA.
And then we correlate the amount of genetic diversity that we observe in any
species at one point in time with the size of the population.
So in essence,
we can use DNA extracted from thousands of these bones to learn how populations
were growing or shrinking or moving across the landscape,
or whether there were local extinctions followed by replacements of populations
coming in from somewhere else.
And we've learned an awful lot of stuff over the last couple of decades of doing
this.
For example,
we've learned that bison horses and mammoths all peaked in population size
around 40,000 years ago and then started to decline.
And this is interesting because two of the main hypotheses about what caused the
mega fano mass extinction at the end of the pleistocene when we did lose
mammoths and many other of these big species were that they didn't like the peak
of the last ice age.
It was too cold and too terrible for them or that people turned up and hunted
them to death.
But at the initial decline begins about 30,000 years ago.
That's 10,000 years before the peak of the last ice age and 15,000 years before
any evidence of large numbers of humans in North America.
So it looks like we're off the hook for the beginning of these extinctions,
although I'm quite willing to let us off the hook for the ultimate extinction
event of many of these species.
We've watched carnivore populations grow and move in response to changes in the
dynamics of the herbivores that they prayed on.
And we're starting to learn why some species like Caribou survived.
They like to live where humans didn't,
which is a pretty good trick.
And other species like cave lions when extinct and I and colleagues who work on
this stuff often get to publish these papers and pretty high profile journals.
They get lots of press attention and people care.
People are really interested.
They call.
I'm often really excited to talk about what we've learned and how it applies to
present day problems and biodiversity conservation,
but they only ever really asked me one question
and it's kind of annoying
and since there really is no sound bite size response to this,
I decided to write this book,
right?
So the field,
the field of bringing extinct species are extinct traits back to life has come
to be known as de extinction.
Now we're all partly familiar with de extinction because we were there when it
happened the first time and we know what happens.
We know it all went off without a hitch.
Everything was perfectly good,
right?
Yeah,
we remember this,
but today we're not going to talk about dinosaurs because we can't clone
dinosaurs.
There are no dinosaur bones that contain DNA.
They're all rocks.
There's no DNA in rocks regardless of what you read in high profile.
Nice publications like science and nature.
There's no DNA in dinosaurs.
You heard it here,
right?
So how are we going to bring back a mammoth?
We know there's DNA in mammoths,
right?
The first step,
the first thing that everybody thinks we're going to do,
the first process that's proposed is,
let's clone it.
Let's clone a mammoth.
Well,
cloning is actually a specific scientific process,
a specific type of work that's actually known as somatic cell nuclear transfer.
So in ourselves we basically have two different kinds of cells,
germline cells,
which are sperm and eggs and somatic cells,
which are everything else.
What normally happens?
A sperm and an egg come together,
fertilized,
create a small thing as I go.
And that differentiates and that particular cell that they create has the power
to become any type of cell in a whole body pair cells,
skin cells,
heart cells,
liver cells,
every type of cell there is somatic cells already know what their job is and
they can't do anything else.
So the idea of somatic cell nuclear transfer is to trick a somatic cell into
forgetting all the instructions necessary to be that type of cell and to revert
into a state where it can actually then become every type of cell in the body
and create a whole being.
So the most famous in the first example of somatic cell nuclear transfer was an
experiment in the mid 1990s that brought us Dolly the sheep.
Probably everybody's heard of this,
right?
This was worked by the Roslyn Institute Scotland.
And they took a somatic cell.
In this case,
it was a mammary cell from an adult sheep.
Uh,
you and they take,
took those cells and basically starved them.
They starve them of nutrients in a dish,
in a lab.
At the same time,
they took an egg cell from a different breed of sheep and they removed the
nucleus,
all the genetic material from that unfertilized egg.
So you had an egg with nothing in it.
And a bill starves starved cells right here.
Put them next to each other as zap him with electricity.
The membrane bursts.
The nucleus here dumps into this cell.
Zap It again and the proteins in that egg is somehow cause the genetic material
from that somatic cell that's been stressed out to forget all the instructions
and turn into the type of cell that can become everything in a particular
animal.
This is then implanted into surrogate host who was yet another species of sheep
or breed of sheep.
And eventually Dolly was born and Dolly was a genetic clone of the memory cell
donor and not avoided the egg cell donor or this surrogate mom easy.
So how do we do with a mammoth,
right?
Well we go out in the field and we find one of these fantastically preserved
mammoths and we removed some cells and then we stress them out.
Then we stick those cells in the nucleus of an egg and it doesn't that little
magic thing.
And then we stick it inside an elephant and you know,
grows up into be a baby,
release it.
And it's called wood.
Right?
Right.
Yup.
Here we have our first problem.
So we do find a lot of incredibly WellPreserved remains up in the Arctic.
This is an example.
This is a a horse jaw that we found up in the permafrost near Dawson city that
dates to some time in the last hundred thousand years or so.
This is one of the very many WellPreserved mummy's that's been found in Siberia
and a couple summers ago there was a report of this incredibly WellPreserved and
mummy that was associated with what looked like a viscous read material that
they thought might be blood right,
but regardless of how well preserved these things are,
there is not going to be a living cell to be found in any remains of any
mammoth.
Once an organism dies,
the cells and the DNA within them begins to get broken down into smaller and
smaller pieces almost immediately.
First,
it's enzymes within our own body that chop up the DNA.
If you're a mummy,
you might have the guts burst and then all of that microbiome that lives in
there,
it's going to circulate throughout the system and those are living microbes that
will just catabolize eat up.
That DNA son is particularly bad.
Uv light will hit those mummies just like it hits us when we're alive and we
walk outside.
But unlike us,
the mummies are dead or the bones are dead.
So there's no proofreading mechanism to fix the damage caused by solar,
radiation,
water,
hydrologist,
hydrolysis,
oxygen.
All these things are terrible for DNA survival.
And in fact,
the DNA begins to break down immediately and it's eventually broken down to a
state where there's nothing that's recoverable where there are no living cells.
There's no living genomes,
there's no intact DNA.
We cannot clone a mammoth.
Thank you for coming.
I'm just kidding.
No,
So what's the next step?
So we all probably heard last week because there was a lot of press attention.
That's a group,
an international group of scientists,
but mostly a,
a group that was in,
in Stockholm,
led by,
uh,
Luva Dolan had published the genome sequences,
complete genome sequences of two mammoths,
one mammoth from Wrangel island that was around 3,500 years old and another
mammoth from Siberia that was somewhere in the realm of 40,000 years old.
So now what we have is this nice big list of Aacs g's and t's the nucleotides
that make up DNA that will spell out the instructions to make the genes that
make the proteins to make a mammoth to make it how it looks and how it behaves.
So surely the best thing that we can do to bring a mammoth back to life would
just be to synthesize these long stretches of DNA and then get them into the
chromosome and then put the chromosome into the egg cell and then,
you know,
do the thing with the going around and making the mammoth,
right?
Yeah.
That,
so the problem with this is that a complete genome,
well there's lots of problems here,
but let's just start with this.
They said it was a complete genome,
but in fact it's not.
It's not really a complete genome.
In fact,
we don't actually know the complete genome sequence of any vertebrate animal,
including humans.
And I know that that sounds a little bit strange since we've been saying for
quite a long time that we know of the human genome sequence.
And to be fair,
we do know most of the human genome sequence.
We know at least all the parts that contain genes,
the important parts that make the proteins that make us look and act the way we
do,
but there are parts of the human genome in of every other mammalian genome and
vertebrate genome that are extremely hard to sequence through these complex
patterns of highly condensed repeat things,
often near the center of the chromosomes and near the end of the chromosomes
that there isn't any existing sequencing technology that can get through and
this means that we don't know the whole sequence.
We don't know how long these are.
We don't know if they're important.
We don't know whether there are any genes in them.
We don't really understand quite yet what they do,
but the truth is we don't have the complete sequence for mammoths.
It's even harder than that,
and there are two reasons why it's harder for anything that's extinct.
In particular,
we're talking about mammoths here than it would be to assemble a complete human
genome.
The first is that the sequences that we recover from these bones are very short
and damaged.
And this is because of all of the stuff that I just talked about.
Solar radiation,
enzyme is from in the body and from microbes that are in the soil that we'll get
into the particular bones after they're buried and eat up the DNA.
All of this stuff is acting to break those DNA sequences down.
So if you imagine that I could get modern DNA out of something that looks like a
nice big party streamer.
Ancient Dna looks more like confetti,
right,
but not confetti.
That's in that good of a shape,
right?
More like confetti that you might find on the ground in the gutter or the day
after the parade.
Right when it rained the night before and maybe there were elephants in the
parade and flux of passenger pigeons flying over and you know,
not,
not good,
it's not good.
The other problem is that the samples are full of all kinds of stuff in addition
to mammoth DNA.
So if you imagine that I took a piece of my own hair or a cheek swab and
extracted all the DNA in there and then sequenced everything I got when I
extracted DNA.
Um,
Martin,
nearly everything that I could get out of there would be my own DNA.
That's cause I'm living and my DNA is in pretty good condition.
Then there's not that much that might be contaminating my DNA sample.
In 2006 I was involved with the group that used the new sequencing technology,
next generation sequencing to shotgun sequence.
That's what we call sequencing everything we get out of the DNA extract a
mammoth bone for the first time and this is what we got about half of the
sequences that we recovered from that sequence map to mammoth DNA.
The rest of it was stuff like soil bacteria,
environmental microbes,
other stuff that was probably also soil microbes that we just haven't sequenced
yet.
So they weren't in the database for us to compare the data to some
contamination.
We often find human dog,
domestic cats and birds sequences in our extracts.
That's not that surprising.
So about half of what we got was mammoth.
We were pretty bummed about this.
We thought,
well,
half,
that's terrible.
How are we ever going be able to piece together a complete genome with only half
of what we're getting is actually ancient DNA?
It turns out several decades or a decade later,
we know that this was actually an exceptionally WellPreserved sample and that
most of the remains that we recover have less than 20 less than 10% of the DNA
that we want is actually the DNA from the host.
If you've heard of the neanderthal genome that was published recently,
the first and the endo tall genome sequence,
they used a couple of different bones and none of those bones bones had more
than 1% neanderthal DNA in them.
That's pretty standard,
especially when you're not coming from a kind of cold region.
So what we have is this kind of junked up bit of Confetti.
If you can imagine confetti that looks more gross than this.
And what we really want are just the purple bits,
right?
So how do we go about finding the stuff that we want from amid the entire mess
of stuff that we actually get?
How do we tell what DNA is mammoth when most of what we're getting is actually
just soil microbes that we really want to throw away?
What we do is we map the data that we have these broken little tiny pieces of
fragments to the already published complete genome sequences of living animals
or complete ish,
right?
They're in good shape.
They're much better than anything that we would be able to generate use from an
ancient sample.
So for the mammoth,
we would map it to an Asian elephant and for the neanderthal are able to map it
to a human.
We take these broken fragments and we matched them where they go using this
genome sequences,
a guide to figure out where they go.
One of the key problems that arises immediately when you think about this is
what if something weird has happened in the evolutionary time between when a
mammoth lived and when the Asian elephant lives since that common ancestor.
If something weird happened,
like a big duplication,
there's a whole new bit of DNA or something changed a lot,
right?
That would be missing.
We wouldn't have that part of the genome on our map.
We would think that whatever it was,
if mammoth DNA that matched that real part of the mammoth genome,
because it's not part of the elephant genome that we're using as a scaffold was
probably just environmental DNA and we would throw it out so it's harder to
generate a complete sequence for something that isn't alive where we can't
generate the genome sequenced by itself.
And one would think that if you're trying to identify the parts of the genome
that are most important to make a mammoth look more and act more like a mammoth
instead of like an elephant,
those might be some of the important places to look.
The other problem is that having the DNA sequence is not the same thing as
having a living cell.
We're getting better at being able to synthesize these long strands of DNA that
we might use to generate a complete sequence,
but we don't know how to wrap those things up properly and get them into a
chromosome in a state where they're actually going to make jeans and make
proteins.
And we don't know how to get chromosomes into a cell in any logical way.
So it looks like if this is the pathway,
plan B is what we're going to use to bring a mammoth back to life.
We're stuck at that first step.
And that's not gonna work either.
Of course there's another way.
So the last plan,
and this is the one that really is at the core of what people are thinking about
for de Extinction,
is to engineer a mammoth.
And this is really similar to just thinking about cutting and pasting your DNA.
So you find a part of the genome that you want to swap out.
Say some gene that's different between elephants and mammoths.
You cut it out and paste in the version that you want.
So mammoths in Asian elephants diverge from each other.
Something like 6 million years ago.
We now have genome sequences from both of these sequences and we can start
combing through those genome sequences to look for places where the two species
are different from each other.
Sequence a whole bunch of Asian elephants finds a place where they're all the
same as each other,
whole bunch of mammas and see where they're all the same.
And if these two are different than that's probably kind of critical to making a
mammoth look and act like a mammoth.
So imagine then you had a little machine that you could use a machine that you
could send into the genome of an elephant cell and identify exactly that place
that you want to change.
And also you could give that little machine a package to take with it,
which was a,
an artificially synthesized bit of mammoth DNA that it would take with us to
this place in the genome.
And that machine could then cut out the elephant version of the gene and swap
the mammoth version gene in there in its place.
Well we have that machine.
That machine is called Crispr cas nine and this is something that you might've
heard a lot about in the news in the last couple of weeks.
There was a Chinese team recently that use this particular enzyme.
This is a naturally occurring enzyme,
not a machine that we've built.
It's something that bacteria and archaea use to protect themselves from invading
diseases.
People have figured out how to use this to harness this machine to identify
parts of the genome and cut it out.
And this Chinese team had done that with human embryos raising all sorts of
ethical issues about this incredibly powerful new technology.
So this machine here,
this molecule here is your,
your little machine.
This is an enzyme and here's the part of it that recognizes a specific part of
the elephant genome sequence.
We send in there a bit of synthesized mammoth DNA.
The machine here chops it in half.
It's like a molecular scissors.
That's its job.
Of course,
the DNA in a cell doesn't like to be in half.
So it has a whole,
it has a couple of different mechanisms that it uses to fix those double
stranded breaks.
We harness the cell's own repair mechanism and stick in there,
that synthetic piece of mammoth DNA.
So we end up with an elephant that's just a little bit mammoth like right,
so what do we change?
I said there are about 6 million years of evolution separating these two species
and indeed there have been some efforts so far within the last couple of weeks
even to catalog the differences that existed between these two guys.
One of the first differences that was found was a work that was done by Kevin
Campbell's lab in Manitoba in 2010 they found that there were only three
differences,
three changes that needed to be made to change the Asian elephant red blood cell
hemoglobin component of the red blood cell,
which is responsible for carrying oxygen around the body into the woolly mammoth
virgin of the red blood cell.
And they made these changes in cells in the lab and they were able to then do a
little tissue tissue culture experiments,
gene expression experiment to try to figure out what those differences did for
that version of the hemoglobin protein.
And they found that when these changes were made,
the hemoglobin was much better at carrying oxygen around the body at low
temperatures.
This is clearly something that is an adaptation that arose in mammoths as the
tropically adapted ancestor of these two species moved out of the tropics and
into the Arctic.
Right.
So this might be a powerful new first approach to going about trying to create
or change an elephant genome so that you could create a mammoth.
So what else should we change?
Well,
there's a team that's nearby here that's led by George Church that had been
working on this for some time and using this CRISPR type of genome editing,
they've so far been able to swap out 14 different genes.
Every one of them that they've tried so far has worked with this CRISPR
technology.
These genes are associated with increasing thermal regulation,
maybe thicker subcutaneous fat layers and and thicker hair or the red blood
cells and also things that are associated with diet and metabolism,
all sorts of things that one might think were important to making an elephant
look and act more like a mammoth.
And so far they have succeeded in creating something that is about a small
fraction mammoth in a dish in a lab,
which of course is a very long way from creating a living,
breathing mammoth.
But it is hopeful and it does say that with this genome sequence which we do
have for the most part and with this CRISPR cas engineering technology which we
also have,
we can then create an elephant cell that's alive that contains a few mutations
that make it look and act more like a mammoth and at that point we can go ahead
and use cloning the traditional technology use to bring something back.
Of course the next step here,
creating a surrogate mom,
growing it up,
putting it in the environment,
I like to call it phase two of the extinction is probably even harder than what
we've been able to accomplish so far.
And when you read about de extinction or hear about it on the radio,
often there's a focus on this first part,
phase one with the thought that just because we can get this far,
it means that we are super close to being able to bring a mammoth back to life.
But that is really,
really not the case.
We are far from being able to create a mammoth.
So the next thing we would have to do in this step would be to find a surrogate
mom.
So for many species,
this might be easy if they have very close evolutionary relatives that are still
alive than it might be relatively straightforward to finding a surrogate mom
that could carry a problem,
an edited embryo or an edited and edited embryo to term.
But the more evolutionary distance accumulates between the living species and
extinct species you're trying to bring back,
the harder this is likely to be.
There may even in some cases be some unpleasant,
uh,
constraints associated with,
with trying to do this.
Um,
I know I say here that you probably don't want to photo,
but you're a bunch of computer sciences,
so you probably do want a photo.
So I'm here is one you're hoping for something grocer,
right?
Yeah,
I knew that.
I'll try to find something gross or for next time.
This is a,
this is a stellar sea cow and this stellar seek out.
This is a foot.
There's a scale bar right there.
This is a big animal.
Steller sea cow.
When extinct a couple of hundred years ago,
we hunted them to death.
One of these guys could feed a crew of 30 or so men for a couple of weeks.
So you can see why potentially they were,
they were nice.
Pray for people who are out on the ocean.
They lived along the coast of California,
up across the Aleutian islands and onto the commander islands and they went
extinct really recently,
a couple of hundred years ago.
The closest living relative to the steller sea cow is a dugong hair.
Right?
And if one were to estimate the size of a newborn steller sea cal by looking at
the ratio of newborn manatee and good dewgong to the ratio,
to the size of their mom,
um,
a newborn steller sea cow would be larger than its mom,
which just wouldn't be pretty.
So in some cases,
there may be some physical constraints,
technical problems,
technical challenges associated with this part of phase two.
It's also pretty clear by now and becoming more and more clear,
uh,
through time that we as organisms and every organism are more than the sum of
just our acs,
g's and t's that make up our DNA sequence.
In fact,
we are a product of both our genome sequences and the environment in which we
live in that environment begins in the womb.
The same would necessarily be true for an elephant or an edited elephant that
was attempting to be a mammoth.
Asian elephants and mammoths genomes are already,
without thinking about anything,
about 99% the same.
But I'm the same as we are and with chimpanzees.
Right?
And so if you put something that's tiny,
tiny bit changed inside a mom who has pretty much the same genome and pretty
much the same genes and the developmental process here is going to be controlled
and affected by her hormonal environment and her diet and what's going on,
how do we know that the changes that we've made are going to have any effect
whatsoever on what this animal looks like and once it's born is going to be born
to and live in an elephant society.
Elephants eat the dung of their moms just after they're born.
In order to establish the microbial community that they need to break down the
food that they ate.
This newborn mammoth elephant hybrid would eat the dog of an elephant so that it
could establish an elephant microbial community.
We know how important the gut microbes are and determining how we look and how
we act and how we feel.
Why would the same not be true for an animal like this?
It would then join an elephant society and eat whatever food elephants are fed
in captive environments and uh,
you know,
all of these things are going to affect the way that this animal behaves and the
way that looks.
This is something that's unquestionable and yet something that we haven't really
questioned.
And speaking of captive environments,
this in my mind is probably the biggest challenge associated with mammoth de
extinction.
We know that elephants don't fair particularly well in captivity.
They often fail to reproduce in captivity if they do,
they injure and sometimes even kill their offspring until we have figured out
how we can meet the physical and emotional psychological needs of mammoths in
captivity.
I think that we should not be using mammoths for this type of research or
keeping them in captivity.
Maybe for other species,
these particular types of concerns are less birds.
We may not to need have birds and bird species might not have very much parental
guidance.
So maybe it's,
it's ethically simpler to bring birds back.
But there are of course technical challenges of bringing birds back that we
don't have when we're dealing with mammals.
So you know,
there are many different ethical considerations to be aware of,
but again,
this is something that I think not enough attention has been paid to and finally
it would be remiss of me not to point out or to acknowledge that the world has
changed a lot in the time since many of these species have gone extinct and
bringing something back and introducing it into an environment where it doesn't
live is definitely going to affect those environments.
Environments are not stable things.
A species doesn't go extinct.
Leaving this giant gaping hole into which we could just stick it back,
they'll change,
they'll adapt.
New Species move in,
everything changes.
This here,
this is the range of the passenger pigeon,
which is one of the species that's been proposed to bring back to bring back to
life,
right?
Where would a passenger pigeon a bird that flocked in the billions and fed on
forests killing huge sways of forests all at once?
Where would it go if we were to bring it back?
Clearly the ecological implications of de extinction need to be considered
carefully for any species that we're considering bringing back.
Before we go down the road to actually making it happen.
So de extinction can we do?
It's not yet.
We can't yet,
but the technology is increasing rapidly both in phase one and in phase two and
there will come a time where we can do this for some species.
So maybe we should start focusing more on the question.
Should we,
and as somebody who's written a book about this,
it's clear that I should have a very informed and direct opinion about this.
And I do.
I don't know.
I honestly don't know.
There are a lot of different species that have been proposed as candidates for
de extinction.
This is the heath hen that used to live in Martha's vineyard,
mammoth passenger pigeon,
thylacine steller sea cow,
the gastric brooding frog,
the Bucardo and type of Ibex that used to live in the parentees.
All of these things have been posed by groups who are interested in working them
to be resurrected.
But I think that the really the most important thing to do and deciding whether
we should proceed with any of these species or any other species that someone
might want to bring back is to really try to understand why.
Why might we want to bring a species back that's been extinct for a long time?
Why is this such a compelling area of research?
Why are so many people so fascinated by this idea?
And to answer this question just in the last few minutes here,
I'm going to return to mammoths and I'm going to kind of ignore the fact for a
moment that it's not possible to do and that ethically it's probably a terrible
idea to deal with elephants and to bring mammos back to life and talk about why
we might want them back.
Because I do think there are a couple of compelling reasons to think about
bringing mammoths back or at least creating an elephant that looks and acts a
little bit like a mammoth.
The first is ecological,
so there's a place up in northeastern Siberia called Pleistocene Park.
It's been established in about the mid 1990s by scientists with the Russian
Academy of Science named Sergei Zimov.
He started buying up lands near his home at the northeast science station and
preparing a park for the resurrection of Ice Age animals.
So far he has bison imported from Canada,
some species of horse,
uh,
five different species of deer and he's been doing some experiments where he's
keeping them out of some parts of Pleistocene Park and letting them graze on
other parts of Pleistocene Park to see what the effect of having those animals
there is on the,
the ecosystem,
the environment itself as a whole.
So here's a picture that surrogate took.
This is very early spring.
This is the side that doesn't have any grazing animals and this is the side that
does have grazing animals.
And what you see here is a really stark contrast between the type of vegetation
that's there.
Here we have pretty much only one species of grass that's very low productivity,
really can't support grazing herbivores in any way.
And over here,
remember this is early spring so the grass hasn't had time to regenerate.
You still see lots of green and you can't really tell,
but there are a bunch of different species of grass that are there.
What he's found is that these animals,
by their presence alone moving around,
turning over the soil,
recycling nutrients,
distributing seeds have essentially created their own habitat.
They've made the habitat that's necessary for them to survive.
In fact,
they've made so much that even after the very cold Arctic winter,
there's still some green grass there left for that community to come back the
next year,
and he's observed not only that these animals are happy and healthy and living
in these areas,
but that other species have come to visit the park because it's such a rich
source of food.
Things like saiga antelope and endangered species.
Essentially these animals with their presence have recreated that rich Tundra
grassland that used to be there potentially making habitat and saving species
that are in danger of extinction today because this is all they've got.
The next reason is more emotional.
I think few of us are willing to accept the idea of a world that doesn't have
elephants,
but elephants aren't endangered species.
Asian elephants are in trouble,
their habitat is declining.
We're having a difficult time stopping poaching.
Human populations are growing and every year fewer and fewer Asian elephants
exist.
What if we could use this technology not to bring mammoths back to life,
but to create elephants that are capable of living in a more diverse
environment?
Elephants that could live in temperate zones or arctic zones moving into the
types of habitats that were once occupied by Mamet's.
We could use this technology not to bring something that's gone and has been
gone for a long time back,
but really to save a species that's still alive today but in danger of
extinction,
let's not use this crazy technology to d extinct mammoths.
Let's use it to save elephants and that's what I think the most compelling use
of the technology that's being developed here really is not to bring stuff back
that's gone,
but to change and manipulate and give a genetic booster shot,
if you will,
to populations and species and communities that are in danger of going extinct
because of our actions today because of climate change,
because of decreases in habitat,
that evolution itself alone can't keep up with this in my mind,
is the most powerful use of de extinction technology.
Thank you for your attention.
I'm happy to take any questions.
If anyone has any,
a fish question comes back to what you said at the very beginning,
which is this,
this is not your,
what your field was halves.
The question caused you to become interested in this question and change what
you're working on or or is it just cost you to write this book that you're,
you're,
you know the tour.
Yeah,
no,
I'm definitely more interested in now and actually writing this book was,
it was an experience in and becoming more and more interested.
We now have a couple of different projects where we're hoping to,
uh,
use ancient DNA technology to learn,
what's the diversity was in populations that were extinct in the past that are
that not extinct,
but where recent changes in population size.
Like I'm a black footed ferrets and the central plains for example,
are nearly genetically Depop,
right?
They're all almost the same and that's because of a recent really tight
population bottleneck and near extinction.
These guys are now in trouble.
There is a disease that's killing them off.
Um,
it's not something that we can do yet,
but it would be possible to look at black footed ferrets that are preserved in
museum collections or living cells that they have in the collection at the
frozen zoo in San Diego and learn how much diversity there was in the past and
then use this technology to inject that diversity and to living populations of
black footed ferrets.
I'm also really interested in birds.
There are tons of species of birds that are in danger of going extinct.
And yet the biggest technical hurdle here is that we can't clone birds.
There's no way to actually get to that egg cell at the point where it's ready.
It's ready to be fertilized,
but it hasn't yet been fertilized because of the peculiarities of the bird
reproductive tract.
And so there is no way to clone birds.
There's a different type of technology that one would use to,
to change the genome sequence in birds.
And we've been working with other groups to try to refine that technology for
endangered bird species.
It's kind of neat when,
uh,
bird chicken egg is laid,
for example,
the,
the germ cells with the primordial germ cells that are going to go on to become
sperm and eggs aren't actually in the gonads yet because the gonads don't exist
yet,
but they're migrating around the,
outside of that embryo to the place where the gonads will be.
At that point,
you can stick a needle in the egg cell and suck out some of those germ cells,
primordial germ cells without harming the embryo or the egg.
And you can put those into a dish and you can actually edit those primordial
germ cells and then you can stick them back into another ag as it's just been
laid.
And they will migrate around the embryo to become those primordial germ cells.
So the egg when it hatches will be totally normal,
but its offspring will have the edits that you've made.
And this is a really cool and potentially powerful technology that's really at
the early stages of being developed.
You taste the question as,
you know,
can we,
and should we do,
do you not feel like we live in a world where it is inevitable that probably
within the lifetime of people in this room,
people will actually decide to do this and they'll,
we'll be baby elephants with a little bit of wooly mammoths or BB humans with a
little bit of Neanderthal or whatever your favorite choice is as one of these
inevitable.
Those are two particularly hard choices,
right?
So,
um,
there,
there are a lot of technical hurdles with both of these and with,
with neanderthals,
there's a big ethical question there.
Nana tells her people too,
right?
So,
um,
how are you going to get informed consent to bring one of those guys back to
life?
You know,
that's a pretty touchy thing,
I think.
I don't think we should go there.
Um,
whether we do or not,
I don't know,
scary,
but,
uh,
there are a lot of scary things that can be done with crispers.
So,
uh,
I don't think we should talk about that.
We'll see through mammoths.
The,
some of the biggest hangups are actually in the cloning process itself.
Um,
and then every time an elephant gives birth,
the hymen actually grows back and the hymen has a tiny little hole in it that's
just big enough for the sperm to get through and it sits there during the
pregnancy to actually maintain the pregnancy.
It's a big heavy thing,
right?
And it's a two year pregnancy,
so you got to hold it in there for two years.
Um,
there's certainly is no way to insert a developing embryo into the uterus of an
elephant without destroying that hymen.
I think that's a,
this stuff is going to involve,
you know,
are creating,
growing elephant eggs on the backs of mice.
I know that there are groups that are actually working on doing that and maybe
completely artificial wombs where the entire gestation process takes place
outside of a,
of a species and all of that stuff might be developed,
probably not de extinction,
probably because we want to use it for humans.
There certainly isn't any money being invested into developing technologies for
the purposes of the extinction.
Um,
but yeah,
do I think that somebody is going to try?
Yeah.
I'm more likely somebody is going to achieve what George Church's lab achieved
and then the press is going to say George Church cloned a mammoth,
which is not what George Church said at all.
Right.
And to be fair,
there was only one,
uh,
media outlet that said that.
So,
and I won't say what it is since I know this is going on youtube
to play devil's advocate here.
So let's say that we succeed in,
in,
um,
genetically engineering.
Elephants have it,
they can survive in different habitats to make nationals living.
Now that that feels to me like,
you know,
going after the same,
we'll,
we've destroyed your natural habitat here,
but we found this other place in North Dakota where you can live.
Um,
and so we're going to genetic genetically reengineer your offspring and have
them go do that.
I'm not saying that this should be a substitute to trying to protect the species
that are alive and in danger today,
but I think that's,
that we have come to a point where we're playing conservation triage and we
might need to reach deeper into our arsenals and find the most powerful weapons
we have to stop these species from going extinct.
I would rather have elephants in Africa,
but I would rather have elephants in North Dakota then no elephants.
So,
but yeah,
I know on the one hand,
I don't like to anthropomorphize the,
the argument,
but I'm going to hit,
if we did anything like that with humans,
it would be,
um,
ethically important and the number of fronts.
Do you have to be tried to save humans from going extinct?
It would be ethically important
worry if we relocated them and said,
[inaudible] genetically engineering use of,
that's going to be okay without consent from the police.
You're making an argument that says we should focus on saving elephants where
they are and I totally agree with you on that.
I completely agree that we should do that,
but I'm saying that it's not enough and it's probably not going to be enough.
There are situations we can't control.
Look at the look at the Rhino,
right?
We haven't been able to save the Rhino,
right.
The cabots hat where it lives is,
is something that we can't,
we can't deal with because of current political situations.
What if we relocate elephants to North Dakota and then in that time when they're
gone completely fixed the political climate and the expansion of human
populations in Africa and then we can put them back in Africa.
Would having them live in North Dakota for a short period of time be a terrible
thing to do?
If our ultimate goal was to create a native habitat for them to thrive as a
living species rather than something that's just gone.
How do we actually know what modifying rich bitch is going to help elephants
live in North Dakota?
We have no idea.
And this is uh,
this is really part of the process.
So we now have these genome sequences,
right?
Which is like somebody handing you two massive phone books for New York City and
San Francisco,
but without any names and addresses them.
Right?
The next step is trying to figure out where the genes are,
what the genes do,
uh,
doing these experiments like George Church in his lab are doing where they'd
switch a little bit out and then they test those cells.
You know,
you can,
you can actually perform some,
some acid in,
in tissue culture and culture to figure out whether those changes have done
something and what those changes might be before using them to go on and make an
animal.
But yeah,
we're very much at the early stages and trial and error.
We don't have to make animals though that are somehow unfit.
We can do those early stages in the lab.
I guess I was thinking like even later,
like we know if we know how to modify the blood cells to live in a colder
climate,
how do we know how much of that we need to do or whether that's going to be
helpful and whether the elephants are even going to survive in North Dakota.
Yeah.
We don't know,
do we?
But,
uh,
yeah.
We'll know more after we've tried than we knew before we tried.
Okay.
All right.
Thank you very much for your attention.